i'm thinking about all the small places
i put myself to
for men wow i should go call my
therapist
and uh have a conversation about this
yeah 100 i know why do we do that
right like i struggle not struggle but i
find myself always contemplating how is
it that
someone like i think of myself as very
fortunate that i was raised by this very
strong mom
she's abroad she's like the
quintessential broad
um and so there's like the strength that
always came
with me just growing up around her and
seeing her
and yet you know i found myself in my
20s and in my early 30s like
and i think back like how i tried to
make myself smaller for a guy or
in a relationship because you think
that's ultimately
the problem and like if you can like
just be a little bit smaller not live
your full potential and just
be okay with just being a little bit
less like everything will be okay and
it's like
what what are we thinking that's
ridiculous
it's hard like unless you're dating
someone
of an equal thing and i i but it's not
like i've just had such a struggle with
men i have a lot to talk to barack my
therapist about later
like and by the way can we do it two for
one
yes yes and by the way i was watching
long shot the other night
and i just loved it and i was having
such a good time
and i love watching you know for me
comedy if i wasn't you know if i didn't
have comedy or i didn't seek comedy or i
didn't immerse myself in the pool of
comedy
i'd be in a straitjacket i say it all
the time hanging upside down like a bat
in fact what what's your favorite funny
movie or what are your favorite funny
movies
oh my gosh so just recently um i had a
little bit of dental surgery and so i
had some downtime
and i re-watched playing trains and
automobiles
that was like one of my favorite
favorite movies but i haven't seen it in
years
oh my god how i mean you have to watch
it again it is
so good it's a masterpiece and i quote
it all the time
uh the other day i was at work and
frankie had her first day of
kindergarten and i was here and i
have made you know every class visit and
you know
everything but of course not the hundred
things i've gotten to do
and but showed up for the one thing i
had to miss was like i was like
a worst parent and i was like oh my god
and
chris miller looked at me and it's the
scene where uh
steve martin is saying he's missing his
daughter's school play
and john candy goes oh yeah those
moments they don't come back
yeah and so of course chris busted that
out it's a masterpiece i love that movie
so much i
love that if i want to think about the
good in the world i can think of you
i want if i want to think about the sexy
and fierce and capacity of the world i
can think of you
i feel that way about you and you
impress me on so many different levels i
i can't even start like i'm i'm obsessed
with your
your beauty regime and on instagram like
i
like i can't get enough of that like
it's basically my new it's my bible now
it's so incredible and then you have to
tell me why your hair is so shiny
oh thank you i found this nude shampoo
and it is making my hair shiny and
lustrous also mr daniel
saying a real tune on it and he makes it
look i mean
by the way your whole look right now i'm
dying the hair sweep and the
the berry makeup it's so beautiful
whoever if you did it or whoever did it
kudos
um so yeah i mean definitely
i could play quasimodo when i come in
here in the morning
so there's definitely a team of
judgers so this is you i'll have mr
daniel
send the text with me because this is
his magic
but i'll send you the shampoo too
because it's amazing
please it's your hair it looks
incredible
well andy warhol said you fall in love
with your eyes closed whether my eyes
are closed or open
i am just madly madly in love with you
i i love you deeply thank you
you